A massive leap in the autonomous vehicle revolution
has arrived with the brand new Velodyne VLS-128.
Ten times more powerful and a third the size
of the previous model, it uses 128 lasers
and new auto-alignment technology to map the
surrounding area with a 300 meter range.
And a new study from Kyoto University’s
Primate Research Institute sheds light on
the origins of our disgust mechanism.
As it turns out chimpanzees will eat seeds
from their own family’s poop right away,
but hesitate before eating from stranger poop.
Vsauce!
Kevin, here.
This is Mind Blow.
After years of work by The Seasteading Institute,
Blue Frontiers is set to unveil the world’s
first floating island.
The island in French Polynesia, will consist
of floating concrete upon which homes, offices,
shops, restaurants, and science research centers
can be built -- and re-arranged as needed.
Blue Frontiers hopes to have a dozen floating
islands that can adapt to changing sea levels
ready by 2020 and to make sustainable communities
on the ocean a viable option for 1 billion
people by 2050.
Researchers at Penn State College of Medicine
believe that we can better diagnose concussions
with saliva.
By testing the levels of microRNAs present
in tiny molecules of spit, the team found
more accurate diagnoses and predictions of
how long symptoms would last compared to traditional
survey tools.
The quick, reliable diagnosis of concussions
and their severity would allow doctors and
sports medicine professionals to harness biomarkers
to implement appropriate treatment immediately.
So maybe spit analysis will be coming to a
future football sideline near you.
Pills with built-in radiofrequency emittors
will make sure you take your prescriptions.
Brigham and Women’s Hospital did a pilot
study involving oxycodone equipped with ingestible
digital biosensors inside gelatin pills.
The pills communicated information to doctors
who were able to see how often patients used
the potentially-addictive medication.
And these monitored patients ended up taking
only a fraction of the prescription to manage
their pain -- a breakthrough that could help
rein in the growing opioid epidemic in the
United States.
Another new breakthrough could make organic
semiconductors a viable alternative to silicon
in phones, TVs, and flexible electronics..
By using a new method of “doping,” which
adds impurities to semiconductors to increase
their conductivity, researchers from Princeton,
Georgia Institute of Technology, and Humbolt
University in Berlin were able to increase
conductivity by 100,000 times.
This would allow for a cheaper and greener
way to create the foundation of modern electronics.
Which means, that phone in your pocket could
eventually be a carbon-based life form.
Kinda.
Buckypaper is looking to make wearable technology
cheaper.
Researchers at the FAMU-FSU College of Engineering
have developed durable, highly-flexible motion
sensors using “buckypaper”, which is a
sheet of carbon nanotubes 50,000 times thinner
than a human hair.
Buckypaper would allow wearable tech to stand
up to the demands of the human experience
at a fraction of the current cost.
Everything from bed sheets that monitor your
sleep to shoes that count your steps and track
your posture are on the table.
Don’t know what to wear?
An artificial intelligence system can learn
your style and suggest outfits.
A team at the University of California San
Diego worked with Adobe to develop a trainable
AI that uses your browsing data to present
images of clothing that you’ll want to put
on -- and it can also design new pieces of
clothing based on your preferences.
This could be extremely helpful for those
of us who aren’t particularly fashionable.
An algorithm can now diagnose pneumonia better
than humans.
Pneumonia is responsible for nearly a fifth
of deaths among children under the age of
5 worldwide and notoriously difficult to diagnose.
It took the Machine Learning Group just one
week to develop the CheXNet algorithm that
analyzes images to spot markers indicating
pneumonia.
After a month of learning, CheXNet was better
at identifying all 14 pathologies.
According to the World Health Organization,
lower respiratory infections account for over
5% of deaths worldwide -- a number that CheXNet
is poised to reduce.
3D printing silicone allows for highly-durable
models with more realistic elasticity.
The Disney Research Institute has pioneered
a method of injecting a variety of materials,
including water bubbles, into MetaSilicone
prints.
The result is output that mirrors the elastic
complexity of the world around us -- including
creating lifelike, multi-density models of
organs that can be used for surgical training.
And bunnies that can safely withstand hammers.
So that's good.
For a clean and easy way to watch every episode
of Mind Blow I created a Mind Blow website
with Squarespace.
I’ve made a lot of websites over the years
and this was by far the most stress-free process
for making a site that looks great and works
great.
You just choose a template, make it your own
and you're done.
So check out the link below to start creating
your website and in the process support Mind
Blow.
Which is officially back.
I’m gonna leave you with the Raven R, the
robot Baidu hopes will be dancing in every
living room -- and as always, thanks for watching.
Okay, mom.
Bye.
What're you doing, Susie?
She wanted to hear the voice going through
the wire.
You can't hear voices in the wire!
Well, how does it work?
How'd your mother's voice get in the phone?
That's simple!
It...
That's funny, I don't know.
I never thought about it before.
We were talking as if we were in the same
room.
How does the telephone work, Uncle Bill?
Magic?
No, not magic, susie, but science.
Science of sound waves and electricity.